a new CDC estimates says drug overdoses
killed a record 72 thousand Americans
last year that's more deaths than caused
by car crashes or guns more than 70
people overdosed on a synthetic
marijuana just yesterday at or near a
Connecticut Park the drug known as k2
can be 100 times more potent than
regular marijuana
Tony Duke opal is in New Haven where
police fear they could get more 9-1-1
calls today Tony good morning a good
morning we can tell you that all but one
patient from yesterday is now out of the
hospital but there are two people in
custody in connection to those overdoses
here and there were a lot of them a very
chaotic scene just walking the park this
morning we can still see tire tracks
converging here where multiple emergency
vehicles were called in response the
calls began at about 8:00 a.m. and for
hours and hours
they just didn't stop as emergency
responders rushed to the scene they
found dozens of people nauseous and
unconscious on the green one man said
they were dropping like the plague just
a scary theme adding to the chaos a
press conference about the overdoses was
interrupted say we're getting another
call of a person just get someone on the
radio more than 70 people were
transported to local hospitals and
officials believe most took the
synthetic marijuana known as k2 I guess
it's appropriate that we're in a lab
because synthetic marijuana is not a
plant at all no it's not it's a chemical
made in the laboratory Yale School of
Public Health Dean says because
synthetic marijuana is newer than most
drugs it has escaped regular oversight
and some jurisdictions this is not
illegal to sell we have a very serious
regulatory and policy gap
New Haven city officials have dealt with
this before 14 overdoses were reported
on July 4th and a Public Safety Alert
was declared after to nearly deadly
incidents in January but fire chief John
Austin says it's a nationwide problem
New York dealt with a similar situation
when nearly 60 people overdosed on k2 in
May
people are self-medicating for several
different reasons and every agency
police fire medical hospitals all are
strained at this time this is a problem
that's not going away and as if the k2
problem wasn't bad enough one of the
medical directors at the hospitals were
over those patients were taken says
there are signs that some of the k2 may
have been dosed with opioids as well
beyond a horrifying scene that police
chief is right this is a nationwide
problem Tony thank you